voici donc le plus célèbre tableau du
mans la joconde oeuvres du maître
italien léonard de vinci acheté par le
roi françois 1er
exposé aujourd'hui au louvre chaque jour
près de vingt mille personnes la
contemple et tente de percer son mystère
car oui mona lisa cash paraît-il un
secret tout d'abord est elle heureuse
réponse de chercheurs anglais en 2006
les chercheurs ont analysé
informatiquement le fameux sourire
résultat elle est et à 83% heureuse 9%
craintive assis pour sont écoeurés
c'était précis mais les chercheurs ne
s'arrête pas là dès les années 70 un
scientifique japonais cherchent à
recréer la voix de la femme mystérieuse
la pérennité et dispose à francesco del
giocondo c'est l'ingénieur suu kyi qui
est responsable de ce petit miracle tous
les fantasmes sont relayés symbole
cabalistiques nombre d'or ou encore
forme de corps caché regardez bien ce
doux de femmes des courbes plantureuses
et maintenant ce dos d'homme disons d'un
éphèbe ils sont tous de cacher dans le
sourire le plus mystérieux le plus
célèbre du monde depuis cinq siècles
celui de la jeu comme les fantasmes se
multiplient la joconde serait en fait un
sainte et pour d'autres un homme ce
chercheur italien la firme sans rire il
s'agirait de l'assistant de léonard de
vinci pendant 25 ans un certain salaï
probablement l'amant du génie un homme
impossible car pour les princesses
strozik la joconde n'est rien d'autre
que leur arrière arrière arrière bref
leur aïeul il y en a qui disent est un
autoportrait que c'est un homme il y en
a qui disent été ni femme ni sommes j'en
ai entendu
toutes les couleurs et c'est normal que
ce soit comme ça parce que voyez 500
dans de mystère semaine bien que ce
pourrait rester comme ça mais l'épreuve
de certaines choses l'histoire parle et
il ya les preuves
on n'y peut rien et si tout ce mystère
était la volonté même dû mettre un
mystère étudier travailler
léonard peigné par couches successives
de glacis aucun coup de pinceau n'est
visible
la photo semble presque flou le
contraste est frappant avec ce tableau
de raphaël soumis lui aussi à la
radiographie assez fascinant finalement
ce cette technique et avec trois fois
rien il suggère a prévu de sourire une
culture comme si la peinture avait une
âme une âme qui s'amusent sûrement de
ces générations de mortel qui tentent de
la décoder
[Musique]